bien
claramente la situación es muy delicada
no obstante creo que podríamos
describirla como estable we can describe
has been 'estable' bots lo que importa
realmente no es solo como la planta
nuclear puede abastecer a la red
ucraniana electricidad sino como la
planta se puede abastecer a sí misma
electricidad manteniendo el reactor frío
y evitando una catástrofe y esa línea de
reserva suficiente para ser estudiada
así que por el momento la planta nuclear
de sap orilla está recibiendo
electricidad de la red ucraniana para
cubrir sus propias necesidades e incluso
si cortarán esa línea de reserva hay
generadores de diésel que pueden
producir electricidad
sin embargo una de las preocupaciones es
cuántos dicen hay y cuánto tiempo
aguantaría en estos generadores si
necesitan usarlos de nuevo para mantener
los reactores fríos como ya pasó en
verano por supuesto el hecho de que sólo
un reactor esté funcionando en estos
momentos y con capacidad reducida ya que
no está conectado a las fuentes de alto
voltaje es un creciente problema
económico para ucrania y un problema
energético respecto a la base teniendo
electricidad
muchos piensan que la verdadera
intención de los rusos aquí es cerrar la
central de la red ucraniana y parar su
producción y en great and sweet stop
provide en el exterior les recuerdo que
la planta proporciona el 20% de la
electricidad ucraniana cuando está en su
máxima capacidad así que en el escenario
más optimista la gente está más
preocupada por quedarse sin electricidad
que por un posible accidente nuclear
además la presencia de los expertos del
oiea en la central genera tranquilidad